verstehst du das trocknet das wirklich
zu
selbst meine mutter glaubte ich sei ihm
fremd gegangen
ich weiß du willst es nicht hören aber
klar ist den an die schuhe zu schieben
war auch blödsinn
dafür habe ich mich entschuldigt
vielleicht ist reese einfach verletzt
ist es eben nicht gesagt hast
deswegen kann er doch noch lange nicht
behaupten ich treibe es mit anderen
männern kommt auch so eine schnapsidee
weil es ihm nicht von anfang an gesagt
hast was ist los
warum hast du eben die tür abgeschlossen
es machst du sonst auch nicht ich habe
mich vorhin in der tiefgarage beobachtet
gefühlt
ich glaube das war nur einbildung aber
das ist nicht alles oder raus mit der
sprache
was hat schon gemacht mag ist verlobt
ja mit franziska franziska ist
wunderschön und sie ist eine
ernstzunehmende künstlerin die hat ihr
studium bestimmt nicht abgebrochen
weißt du wie kleine ich mir vorkam
du hast dich vom markttrend
ich habe eine überraschung für dich ich
auch für dich du wirst nicht glauben für
welches modell sich brockmann media
entschieden hat so die bitte er ist doch
super oder
er ist auch ein gut aussehender mann wie
wir gestern abend feststellen konnten
das geht nicht
wieso nicht weil wir das gemeinsam
entscheiden wollten und nachher sagen
alle er hätte den job nur durch
beziehungen bekommen
vitamin b schade doch nicht 16 würde ich
auch mit in die geplanten events
aufnehmen
eine aufstrebende band mit gut
ausgebildeten musikern auf die passt
auch bilden für das leben die faust aufs
auge
na ja noch ist gar nicht sicher ob wir
alle ganz ausrichten können ich bin
optimist schon fast künstlerisch
franziskus arbeiten oder und meine
überraschung
ich war gestern noch einmal hier mein
fahrer zu holen raten mir hier lukas er
saß an deinem computer
ich weiß erzeugt wurde gesagt angeblich
wollte er nur etwas ausdrucken
aber dann habe ich zuletzt geöffneten
dokumente gesehen
unser - aber ich habe heute schon mit
unserem edv techniker gesprochen und es
gibt tatsächlich ein drucker problemen
und den finanzplan habe ich mir gestern
selbst angesehen lukas hat die wahrheit
entspricht
warum willst du da nicht mit ihm ins
büro wollte sie nicht begleiten
er möchte es langsam angehen lassen das
heißt er meint es ernst
außerdem hat er einen anruf erst
bekommen als wir uns schon längst
verabschiedet hatten